[Musique]
notre voyage commence en mésopotamie
avec les Sumériens qui ont inventé l'écriture
les énigmes de la préhistoire partent
puis le pas vers l'histoire qui fait ses débuts
dire les faits non plus avec le
mot mais par écrit aux Sumériens
arriver les Babyloniens qui forment un
empire en soumettant les peuples voisins
cependant cette promiscuité forcée de
les gens avec des langues et des coutumes
différentes causes malentendus e
conflits personnels à la discipline
l'ordre le roi de babylone hammourabi
formuler et traduire dans toutes les langues
connu
le premier code législatif de l'histoire
oeil pour oeil et dent pour dent
si un homme casse un os un autre qui
un os est cassé
si un homme tue la fille d'un autre
sa propre fille sera mise à mort
si quelqu'un est volé, vous respectez le
mât de son lot et de la communauté
il compensera le bien volé mais
si le voleur est trouvé, qu'il soit mis à
la mort c'est lui qui l'a acheté
le butin
[Musique]
dans la région de canaan les juifs ont
rassemblèrent leurs tribus pour former le royaume
d'Israël
le plus notable de leurs rois est Salomon
le premier à enseigner l'éthique
mon fils ne génère aucun mal
contre ton voisin et préserve le tien
bouche de tous les mensonges
rappelez-vous que celui qui cultive avec soin
sa terre aura toujours de quoi manger
abondance
tandis que celui qui se perd dans le bavardage
inutile
c'est un imbécile qui aura toujours faim
[Musique]
dans l'ancien iran au nom du dieu
Les mazda persans sont sacrifiés
les animaux et les hommes un mystique de Zoroastre
condamne ces rites et dès les premiers
notions d'enfer et de paradis
Je méditais dans le désert quand le dieu Mazda
il est apparu pour m'apprendre qu'après le
décès
chacun de nous sera considéré comme le méchant
ils subiront alors le châtiment éternel
tandis que les disciples du bien revivront
sur cette terre où le mal n'existe pas
ça n'existera plus et le bonheur sera éternel
[Musique]
dans les montagnes de l'himalaya dans un
petit royaume guerrier de la culture
médical
vive le prince des cèdres parmi les inspirateurs
du bouddhisme une nuit méditant ci-dessous
une figue
J'ai atteint l'illumination parfaite J'ai
compris que l'homme est un esprit éternel
qui passe par différentes étapes et que l'une des
ces stades et la condition d'être
l'être humain le seul qui connaisse la souffrance
cette souffrance conduit l'être humain à
mener des actions confuses qui
activer le karma un certain nombre de causes e
des effets qui causent les maux de
ce monde
cependant, se débarrasser du karma est possible
il suffit de pratiquer une méditation
prudent et n'importe qui peut y accéder
vérité supérieure dans le nirvana en se libérant
du cycle de réincarnation et de
il n'y a donc pas de dieu
qui décide de nos vies comme non
J'existe là l'âme une mort l'homme
de ses actes il est seul responsable
de leur propre destin
[Musique]
nous continuons notre voyage en chine
fragmenté en royaumes guerriers
le laos mystique rejette une société basée
sur les armes et prêche la bonne façon de
atteindre le bonheur
[Musique]
le but vital de chaque homme devrait
être de revenir au simple
loi de la nature aussi longue
le voyage commence pour un petit pas
nous commençons par nous abandonner à
fatalité en ne se soumettant à aucune
désir effort physique tension mentale
ou on passera le dualisme incessant
des lois de la nature yin et lo
yang et nous atteindrons l'équilibre tau
parfait qui soutient l'univers en donnant
confiance en la puissance divine de la nature
le sage ne veut pas et de pas
promenade et rivas
[Musique]
confucius conseille sur les principes
désaccord héréditaire
[Musique]
cher professeur laos parler de la nature
lui attribuant des pouvoirs divins mais pas
parle-moi d'âme de divinité et de
sujets abstraits intéressons-nous
plutôt aux problèmes concrets de
sociétés telles que le bien-être du peuple e
la conduite des gouverneurs afin que
la pauvreté et la richesse sont considérées
honteux
[Musique]
dans la grèce antique, athènes est la ville la plus
puissant des villes indépendantes mais dans
la guerre continue contre sparte
l'Athénien Thucydide et l'observateur de
ce conflit n'existe pas du tout
volonté divine d'intervenir dans
actions humaines au mépris des lois
des dieux et des hommes de ce monde
la violence règne
J'ai vu tant de jeunes anéantis
de la guerre tant de sang à effacer pour
toujours leurs espoirs de revenir à
vivre heureux entre amours et rires
de chansons
[Musique]
un philosophe qui parle habite athenes
avec les gens pour les amener à remettre
question ce qu'ils savent et socrate
le père de la rationalité tu sais
toi-même et ce que tu es vraiment
être mortel et non un proche parent
des dieux
si cela reflète j'ai vu la même chose je pourrais
reconnaître vos limites mais aussi les
tes chances si tu te libères
les préjugés des dogmes religieux des tabous
des illusions du jugement des autres
de la gloire et de l'horreur tu découvriras le
votre essence la plus profonde est la psyché
ce n'est qu'alors que vous pourrez affirmer que vous
sait
[Musique]
le tona disciple de socrate juge
éducation strictement spartiate qui
il exalte au culte du corps et de la morale
des femmes qu'il aime et préfère
réfléchir sur des idées suprêmes telles que la
bien et le beau professeur bien-aimé socrate
Je trouve scandaleux que le nôtre
les gouverneurs vous ont mis à mort
dans ma république idéale, l'amour est
partagé avec d'autres à travers le
dialogue dans l'effort commun pour
connaître la vérité c'est l'amour
le vrai bonheur est platonique
[Musique]
les guerres entre athènes et sparte
affaiblir la Grèce alors
envahi par le roi de macedoine philip ii e
par son fils Alexandre le Grand
tuteur d'alexandre et d'aristote
philosophe qui détient la preuve de la
essai
[Musique]
d'après mon ami platon c'est
il suffit de se consacrer à l'idéal et de
parfait mais la réalité est dans les choses
concret dans l'animal dans le végétal dans le
rochers
l'homme a une intelligence qui
ça devient puissant quand c'est logique et c'est avec
la logique à laquelle nous pouvons arriver
vérité
sur la base de principes stricts
irréfutable de la moindre pierre
au revoir lui-même
demandons-nous toujours en tout
occasions qu'est-ce que c'est
[Musique]
épicure est un philosophe qui se moque de
destin et superstitions
débarrassons-nous des idées absurdes le jour J
ils ne sont pas observés et ils ne nous jugent pas de
par conséquent nous sommes les seuls à décider
ce qui se passe sur terre
la mort alors quand on y est vivant
il n'y a pas de mort et quand la mort vient
nous ne sommes plus là et donc une peur
illusoire inutile de craindre la douleur
aux deux bouts ça devient supportable non plus
mène à la mort et devient un
inquiétude inutile c'est pourquoi si un
jour où je devrais mourir je le ferai entouré
de mes amis et bu du bon vin
sans me casser la tête avec des dilemmes
inutile
[Musique]
en palestine tenant une révolte des
juifs les romains arrêtent jésus de nazareth
un homme charismatique qui agit sur les foules
[Musique]
mais la révolution de jésus est spirituelle
appelé fils de dieu par les siens
disciples jésus prêche la bonté comme
volonté divine et place l'amour au-dessus de tout
Qu'est-ce
on m'a dit oeil pour oeil et
dent pour dent
mais je vous dis de ne pas opposer le mal avec
mal si quelqu'un te frappe
joue
donne-lui l'autre et pardonne-lui comme
Père céleste vous pardonnera quand
vous pécherez car vous êtes tous des dieux
pécheurs et celui qui n'a jamais péché
que tu jettes la première pierre
en vérité je vous dis de faire attention car je
des serpents et des bonbons comme des colombes quand
parler
répondez oui ou non parce que quoi
vous ajouterez sera à votre détriment et non
s'inquiéter pour demain
chercher le royaume de dieu est tout cela
les choses seront données en plus
[Musique]
à rome l'empereur marcus aurelius e
même un philosophe ne s'énerve pas
des échecs si vous savez affronter les
la vie avec raison, calme et
discernement sans rien attendre de
personne et sans avoir peur de rien
tu arriveras où tu veux et personne n'ira
ne t'arrête jamais
[Musique]
contrôler son immense territoire
l'empire romain est divisé en deux
de l'Empire romain d'Orient
l'empereur le plus important et Justinien
père du système juridique actuel
afin que personne ne s'arme au nom de
vendettas privées
J'ai formulé une loi pénale pour moi
crimes et pour les peines c'est un droit
privé pour les relations interpersonnelles a
droit public pour les activités de
l'État est une loi ecclésiastique pour
églises auxquelles je ne délègue pas de pouvoir
temporel mais seulement le domaine
spirituel
[Musique]
en arabie le royaume de sheba et à la fin
dans ce désert traversé par des tribus
Bédouin de foi polythéiste un mystique
Muhammad révèle qu'il a des visions
J'ai prié quand l'archange gabriel c'est moi
est apparu m'ordonnant de prêcher
parole d'allah
le créateur de tout ce qui existe
au cas où dans la fatalité ils seraient à la base
de ce qui se passe
dans l'univers et dans la vie de l'homme
tout fait partie d'un design
impénétrable d'allah le plus puissant et
lui seul dans sa miséricorde a
le pouvoir d'aider l'homme et de
accordez-lui ses grâces
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
notre voyage continue au japon
où les empereurs sont réduits à un seul
rôle symbolique alors que le pouvoir est
divisé entre les seigneurs locaux et les chefs
de l'armée est l'ère de la première
kamikazes qui repoussent l'invasion de
monde là-bas et des samouraïs qui offrent le
leur service armé aux nobles
dans ce contexte instable un moine
maître dogen enseigne la maîtrise de
si zen, le zen est une expérience qui est
s'entraîner à s'asseoir pour méditer tout en vivant
le silence tu percevras ton corps
et votre esprit en effaçant
pensées de toutes sortes vous trouverez
harmonie avec les hommes et ordre
cosmique essayez-le par vous-même
rien de facile rien de difficile pour
résoudre un problème
asseyez-vous et méditez
[Musique]
nous sommes arrivés au seizième siècle
un siècle de grands changements colombo
découvre l'amérique magellan complète le
autour du monde montrant que la terre
c'est rond Erasmus re traduit l'évangile
accusant l'église de manipuler
les textes sacrés que martin lutero dénonce
la cupidité des papes et édicte la
Réforme protestante à Florence
niccolò machiavel écrit un traité
de la doctrine politique
votre banque et vos pourboires amoraux ont
un grand succès
la fin justifie les moyens peu importe
le chemin tant que l'objectif est atteint
ce sont donc les vertus d'un bon prince
gouverner dans son propre intérêt
personnes
la capacité de mentir et l'absence de
scrupules
au-delà des lois et de la morale
[Musique]
un autre florentin Giovanni dellacasa
ambassadeur apostolique à venise e
fréquentateur des entreprises de l'époque
formuler un code de conduite
étiquette
[Musique]
réfléchissons aux mœurs que l'homme
devons prendre dans la société quand nous sommes un
table retenons-nous de faire des bruits qui
désolé pour les oreilles
[Musique]
on évite d'ennuyer ceux qui sont dedans
notre entreprise avec des discours
compliqué ne nous approchons pas trop
qui nous écoute pour ne pas souffler
notre souffle sur le visage
[Musique]
on laisse parler les autres sans
interrompez-les et rappelez-vous toujours que
si trop parler conduit à trop s'ennuyer
se taire conduit à la haine
[Musique]
se heurtant à l'inquisition qu'il avait
brûlé vif Giordano bruno pour sa
les idées sont l'univers galileo galilei père
de la physique moderne affirme que
la terre tourne autour du soleil
l'intention de l'esprit saint
inspirer la bible était d'enseigner
aux hommes comment aller au ciel et non
comment va le paradis comment aller au paradis e
juste pertinence de la théologie, mais
savoir comment va le ciel est le travail de
science en formulant des hypothèses et en vérifiant
le tout avec des calculs mathématiques que Dieu a
écrit le livre de la nature avec quelques
figures géométriques pour que l'homme avec moi
ses sens peuvent connaître les lois
naturelles et contrôlez-les par vous-même
intérêt
[Musique]
l'inquisition frappe aussi en france
mais le mathématicien rené descartes l'a fait
refuge dans les Pays-Bas protestants e
avec son doute systématique
révolutionne la philosophie et la théologie
il n'y a ni magie ni surnaturel
l'homme doit avoir plus confiance en
propre raison et rejeter et quoi
cela ne lui semble pas évident l'univers et le
les êtres vivants sont tous régulés par
mécanismes calculables nous pouvons
expliquez-les par des causes naturelles
physique et avec des lois fondamentales
immuable mais explicable
il n'y a pas de divinités dans les lois
cosmique et même pas dans les affaires humaines
nous ne devons pas déformer la réalité de
choses mais parions sur nous-mêmes
plutôt qu'à propos de dieu
[Musique]
en angleterre vit et le physicien isaac
newton père de la science moderne
J'ai formulé les trois lois universelles de
mouvement
J'ai créé le calcul e
développé la théorie des couleurs i
posé les bases de la mécanique classique
et j'ai décrit la loi universelle
de la gravité mais la gravité explique
le mouvement des planètes mais n'explique pas
ce qui les met en mouvement
J'en déduis qu'il y a un dieu qui gouverne
toutes les choses
[Musique]
au royaume uni le glorieux éclate
Révolution anglaise les souverains sont
relégué aux cérémonies officielles mais
malgré cette évolution politique
l'idée que le mari domine sa femme
combien d'heures sur ses sujets il reste
immuable une savante marie et installez
conteste l'idée que l'homme est plus
capable de la femme dans notre monde comme ça
civilisé
les femmes sont toujours considérées
subordonné inférieur aux hommes mais si
tous les hommes naissent libres comme jamais
toutes les femmes sont nées esclaves pour nous
les femmes ne sont pas autorisées à participer
université dont nous sommes exclus
contribuer au développement de la société
dont nous faisons également partie
le stéréotype qui nous est cousu
le port est celui des femmes frivoles
pendant qu'ils discutent avec les voisins
offrant un joli spectacle et quand
l'un de nous commet des actes de
grandeur indéniable
on dit qu'il a dépassé la limite de
le sexe ne te semble pas ridicule
un jour pas loin les femmes
ils obtiendront le contrôle complet de la
leurs choix de vie sont inévitables
[Musique]
la glorieuse révolution anglaise génère
un mouvement intellectuel et scientifique
l'illumination est remise dans
la matière à la lumière de l'esprit
critique et le rôle de dieu de
la religion du roi de l'État sont
contestée par de nombreux intellectuels tels que
jean jacques rousseau le père de
moralisme moderne
l'homme naît bon mais vit ensuite
enchaîné cela le rend injuste et le
la responsabilité incombe à l'entreprise et au
ça t'empêche de vivre pour ce que c'est
bon sauvage suivant la nature e
instinct s'il pouvait satisfaire
l'alimentation avec le ramassage et le
besoin sexuel avec rencontres
occasionnel
l'homme ne dépendrait de personne al
au contraire, il est prisonnier des dogmes
improuvable d'une dictature appelée
démocratie qui impose à la minorité
des idées que cela rejette
[Musique]
la flotte anglaise contrôle les mers et
la traite des esclaves est pratiquée à
légalement mais un député britannique
William Wilberforce s'oppose à la
l'esclavage jusqu'à ce qu'il soit complet
l'abolition quand je considère l'ampleur
de la question que j'ose poser au
Parlement britannique
l'abolition de l'esclavage je demande
que cet horrible commerce soit
considéré comme dépréciant pour le nôtre
autorité
Je vous laisse imaginer ces millions de
des innocents enchaînés et entassés
sur les autres
ce fléau ne doit plus exister est
notre devoir de reconnaître légalement
dont tout homme se soucie peu
la couleur possède les mêmes qualités que
tous les autres êtres humains
[Musique]
toujours au royaume uni le naturaliste
charles darwin considère la race humaine
comme une espèce qu'on voulait en partant
d'un ancêtre commun le singe est
inévitable que l'homme découvre être
qu'est-ce qui est vraiment un animal et non
le roi de la création placé sur
le sommet du monde voudrait que je sois là
Bible
l'homme appartient plus naturellement à
une variété de singe qui se distingue par
l'usage du mot mais qui a évolué
douloureusement pendant des millions d'années
lutter comme tous les autres pour la
survie de sa propre espèce
[Musique]
nous sommes au début de l'ère industrielle
avec le capitalisme permettant
maîtres pour s'enrichir au détriment de
les salariés contre cela
exploitation de l'homme par l'homme
l'économiste allemand Karl Marx théorise
un nouveau courant politique
communisme
[Musique]
au lieu d'éliminer les inégalités,
structure du capitalisme à la société en
une voie sociale
cela génère une discrimination entre
ouvriers et patrons en créant des classes
social et le conflit quand au lieu de cela dans
une société juste
le profit de la production doit
être équitablement répartis entre les
les ouvriers et le maître
contrairement à l'oeil de la religion
ceux qui espèrent trouver dans l'au-delà
ce qu'il est rejeté dans celui-ci
la vie
le communisme est une forme de société où
l'homme se place maître des siens
propre destin dans cette vie même
car il n'y en a pas d'autres
[Musique]
Oui
à la fin de la Première Guerre mondiale
La république allemande en soutient une nouvelle
idéologie nazisme médecin autrichien
de confession juive sigmund freud se réfugie
puis au royaume uni où il l'a étudié
état mental et fonde la psychanalyse
révolutionner trop de psychiatres
interdits obligent l'être humain à
renoncer à de nombreux besoins provoquant
de perturbations dans son comportement
poussé par sa nature vers le
besoin de trouver du plaisir avant tout
sur le plan sexuel l'homme se retrouve
censuré par sa propre conscience morale
et religieux
une lutte pour harmoniser et la
les pulsions qui l'animent
et cela produit des phobies de
hallucinations des maux de l'esprit qui
le rendre fou
[Musique]
Inde
occupée par l'Empire britannique est
libéré du mouvement politique
du père de l'avocat Mohandas Gandhi
de la non-violence rejette la violence
comme stratégie de lutte pour la vie
comme un cycle sans fin de douleur là-bas
la violence en génère toujours une nouvelle
la violence la seule arme capable de gagner
cette résistance maléfique et passive
[Musique]
l'agressé ne réagit pas
provocations des violents mais protestation
fermement par un boycott pacifique
nous pouvons vaincre la haine avec l'amour
nous pouvons vaincre le mensonge avec le
la vérité suffit qu'un seul
pratiques individuelles non-violence
pour que cela se répande partout dans le
monde
dans le passé le tibet était un empire mais
aujourd'hui il est annexé à la république populaire
Chinois
depuis lors le dalai lama tenzin va te faire [ __ ]
actif pour la libération du tibet
répandre des messages de paix dans tout le
monde
nous les hommes vivons tous
même planète devenue une
informations sur le village global oui
ils se propagent à la vitesse de la lumière est
ce qui se passe dans n'importe quel endroit
loin du monde ça touche tout
la planète
[Musique]
ce que nous faisons interagit avec
les autres et ce que font les autres
interagit avec nous dans cette situation
d'interdépendance pour agir dans la nôtre
intérêt
nous devons avoir l'intérêt à l'esprit
des autres
il s'ensuit que seulement avec la politique
de gentillesse on peut en avoir un
de meilleures conditions de vie pour tous
[Musique]